barstool big cat right here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you bar still big cat
what's up cat I am doing great rich I
apologize that it took so long let's
give what happened well let me ask you a
question
if JJ Watt had texted you I assume you
have JJ Watts phone number if JJ Watt
had texted you the half hour ago and
said hey I want to call into the show at
2:20 Eastern yep would I have been
bumped no you wouldn't have because I am
a man of my word my word is my bond and
I'm like you know I got barstool big cat
220 can I can I get you to do it a
little later well here's the other part
of it in a podcast world when you tape
an interview that you know is a good
interview and your interview was great
and it was a very fun time we had a
great time I would agree everyone loved
it but when you take something that you
know is good it's nice to hold it in
your back pocket because you just know
maybe there's a weekend where there's
not a lot to talk about like this past
weekend or weekend so we're gonna run a
great interview to carry the show ok
Harry the show today so thank you ok
barstool big cat now here on the Rich
Eisen show just describing my my
conversation is feller right here on the
program very good I appreciate that Dan
I hope and I hope it filled that all for
you please get it did I you know I
thought we could have gotten done a
little more Game of Thrones no you
didn't care about it Dan
see now that's the thing to it by the
way you have cornered the market on so
many great things in our industry which
is number one asking a question you have
no no interest in the answer to that the
joke is in the question yeah you do that
a lot yeah I got a lot of that right
there so right for you right here dan um
right here on the show how does it feel
to be a fan of a school whose football
team by kicking a field goal out scores
the basketball team by one every single
time that's good ok so I think being a
fan of Wisconsin in the last 15 years
has been a lot better than being a fan
of Michigan I don't I'd say 29 wins
better in terms of football is that
right yeah
yeah yeah 29 wins in the last 15 years
and I even threw in a Lloyd Carr year
for you just just so that you can't you
can't scream that I'm being biased and
picking a completely arbitrary date
right I we got into it on part of my
take and my point remains what you did
is you did you made me attack something
I actually like I actually liked Jim
Harbaugh I think Jim Harbaugh is a good
football how did I make you attach him
Harbaugh well because Michigan fans
delusional Michigan fans think Jim
Harbaugh is a great football coach they
think he is a special football coach
they think he is Urban Meyer they think
he is Nick Saban they think he's Dabo
Swinney they think he is in that
conversation and the problem is he just
isn't well what have I ever said that
well what have I ever said that are you
aren't you holding against me what you
think other Michigan fans hope for in
their coach well as Michigan thinks that
they matter still and my point my
underlying point when we when we talked
about on the show is ohio state owns
michigan and i don't see i know i know
the the the common response would be
well it's a rivalry that goes in waves
and it goes up and down and sometimes
michigan's on top sometimes ohio state's
on top right it's been 20 years now and
if you look at what ohio state does they
evolve they adapt they have they have
gone into the next century in terms of
football whereas michigan has not and
Jim Harbaugh has had a chance of
multiple time in this past this past big
game
yeah was I was there I was in the house
I was in Columbus cuz you're cuz you're
your but you're their big J journalist
right as I love the Big Ten football I
am passionate about Big Ten football you
are but he liked the fact what happened
on that on that Saturday afternoon is
embarrassing for Michigan and I don't
see any like yeah okay maybe they'll get
their number once or twice but if Jim
Harbaugh stays there for the next ten
years right oh hi of state stays doing
what Ohio State has done it will be I
don't know maybe you're lucky if you
went to a big time because isn't isn't
it true though that what you're doing
right now by holding me responsible for
what you think is Michigan football
fandom
at large the fact that you feel
compelled to do that
isn't that an indication of just how you
feel
Michigan is viewed in a way that
Wisconsin is not the fact that you are
upset that we don't think about
Wisconsin as much as you clearly think
about Michigan you're and that you're
holding that you're holding that against
me personally just because I don't wake
up thinking what's Paul Chryst doing
today
that you hold that against me like oh my
gosh what's what's Hornibrook doing
right now like I'm not thinking that
your big cat steak here though is that I
know Wisconsin doesn't matter
I know Wisconsin doesn't matter we you
know I'm Wisconsin is a very good
football program at this point right
always competing in the big ten nine ten
wins pencil assists that's good for you
doesn't matter that doesn't matter if
I'm talking about competing for national
championships Michigan is no closer to
that than Wisconsin you're the same
exact school Michigan State is actually
farther advanced in terms of that and I
don't think I'm gonna ask you this put
you on the spot
do you Harbor mmm has what it takes to
get Michigan to the playoff yes I do
okay I disagree I know you disagree and
the fact that you are doing that and
pointing it out when you actually deep
down believe in Jim Harbaugh's ability
again just points out some sort of
inferiority complex that you have as a
Wisconsin fan because they can hold on a
second because again Michigan versus
Notre Dame that kicked off the college
football season one of NBC's
highest-rated college football games of
the year the fact that Michigan Michigan
despite its unfortunate big game
appearance despite all that still got a
bowl game right there on on a huge bowl
day because Michigan draws the eyeballs
and draws the interest and Trust the
hate big-cat draws the hate clearly
this is where it this is where it gets
sad because what Michigan has become is
what you just said michigan is ratings
and we're happy to be in a New Year's
Day bowl game but not in the college
football championship no like that means
Michigan does not matter anymore doesn't
matter of course I want to be in a
different situation with that I'm just
you're talking about Michigan's
relevance and the interest level and I'm
pointing out that you're way off base do
you think JJ Watt would be on your show
if you didn't pound the table for
Wisconsin as much as you do do you think
you have a phone number if you weren't
such a badger Homer I'm a little bit
different I actually think I'm pretty
honest about about Wisconsin sports more
so than most Michigan fans and you in
particular are very honest where where
they are and not really matter I am
honest about the the perfect Wisconsin
season is lightning in a bottle in terms
of schedule you saw that last year or
Russell Wilson that year I'm very honest
I've actually everyone who's been
listening to me over the years knows I
was at the Duke Wisconsin Final in
Indianapolis for the Final Four the the
Wisconsin beating Kentucky was one of
the best nights ever and when they lost
to Duke I said as I'm walking out of
that stadium I said we will never be
back at this point ever ever we will
never ever be back at this point because
Wisconsin just doesn't do you know they
don't recruit the type of athletes to be
consistently at the top level of comical
you know college athletics and I
understand that and I'm very open about
it I root for my team I know we
ultimately don't matter and that's why I
as someone who doesn't matter can say to
you hey rich guess what Michigan no
longer it's just that you'll never drag
us down you're we're all just not Ohio
State is all of our daddies that's it I
could have said I could have sat here a
big cat and said you know what after
Robert tractor-trailer crapped out that
we would never be back in some sort of
college basketball perch I could have
thought the same thing as you because
Michigan doesn't recruit the type of
athletes the one-and-done athletes that
Kentucky or Duke does but
who was in the national championship
game two times in the last five years
who's potentially back in that mix yes
again you're talking I'm saying it's the
thirty year anniversary of Glen Rice
that's coming up this year I could have
sat there thirty years ago saying will
never be back there again we'll never do
this again
I'm never gonna give up just never
because I have the heart of a champion
no okay what you do is you have
delusions thinking the Midwest stuff
that everyone just shoves in your brain
when you go to Hannah Harbor for years
and and you stand-in up in a puddle of
water at Rick's in the basement Oh Rick
I think it's a good college experience
and then you come out and say yeah we
matter and we what do we matter for we
matter for ratings and losing national
championship Oh no matter my gosh
alright so let's move on quickly to
something more compelling now that
you've had me as a guest who's who's the
guest that you really want on the show
who's your who's your great white whale
have you had Costas on yet no we've not
had caught on as you would ask my ton of
questions that you have no interest in
the answer to and just use his resume as
the joke sounding yeah
udi right Costas would be very
interesting we want we're currently in
communication with Kevin Durant so a lot
of the times it's guys who we are
critical of and you know JJ Watt was one
of them we were very critical to JJ Watt
and he's become a friend and so shifting
from being critical of someone and then
finding a way to you know have them on
and kind of show a different side of the
person to our audience okay so Durant so
you've been critical why are you
critical of Durant
I think Durant I think he cares like a
little too much heat pretends he does
that thing where he's like I don't care
what the people say but then reads every
Instagram post and gets in fights with
like 14-year olds on the comments
section of his Instagram page okay so
you just just just say that you do care
and I think people really like people
kind of move on but you can't say well I
don't care what people say and then have
a burner account you know what I mean
that's true do you want to do a
makeshift start bench cut with big cat
Brock no don't you want to so so we have
a stick on this show
big cat of a start bench cut where you
got a you got to start when you got a
bench when you got a cut one okay we
give you three choices here we go go
ahead quiet alright do you have the
music right there Mike tell to focus we
have some that's this is our production
value here your yours was setting up the
coffee cups in the background with us
having our conversation so go for it
Brock yeah yeah because start bench cut
of a guests on your show
rich Dan Patrick Scott Van Pelt ah
that's easy
start Scott Van Pelt bench Dan Patrick
cut ready I'm friends with Scott I have
had we've had Dan Patrick on multiple
times we're very good friends with the
Dan ATS
and you yeah you still think Michigan
matters I can't deal with that type of
delusion that's like you you're the guy
who shows up in the huddle and I'm like
alright rich you know go go set a screen
over there and then you're chucking
40-footers thinking you're the best
player on the team mm-hmm now Michigan
are you you need to watch the television
portion of this conversation when we
tweet it out later if you're not
watching right now cuz would you want to
describe my sweater it's a big cat right
I mean look there was one of the
funniest questions I've ever heard it's
very dad like today I think you really
are very stylish today it's like your
sweaters I think your sweater your
sweater game is on point we can all hope
to someday get to that point of that's
like you basically you know when people
buy flashy cars just cuz they want
everyone to see how much wealth they
have and I'm not saying that that's what
you're doing with your sweaters but it's
an air it's like the Jim Nantz look you
know what I mean you walk into a room
and people say this guy is important and
he probably has like a six handicap does
this show that I have a six handicap I
mean you don't have a six handicap I
know that for a fact
quad wear this sweater more if it makes
people think that I've got a six
handicap I'll take that I was trying to
compliment you know by the way
definitely we were not they were
definitely
I love it man what you and uh and PFT
comment or doing it's it's it's a fun
little little I guess little call it a
swordfight side no no no no by the way
no no no hold on a second I hate it when
people use that that word it's it was
like it's like it's like a little sword
fight but yeah your podcast is huge it's
monumental how does that sound is that
good it's in rich aizen's mind it is the
Michigan of podcast oh my gosh that's
perfect right dude it is perfect just
tweeted a game of Thrones question if
you want to take this I'll take it I'll
take it love who's your favorite
direwolf oh my gosh who's my yeah great
song it doesn't care the the mascot of
the Philadelphia Flyers just answer that
okay that's that's that's my biggest
direct answer is ghost guns but he
doesn't care they don't watch Game of
Thrones I know someday someday I'm gonna
watch it the anxiety of being like I
need to sit down and watch this show for
the next however many you know hours it
takes and finished it's overwhelming and
then I'll sit there and just not do
anything for those hours which I could
have been watching it but it feels a
little bit more liberating knowing that
I haven't you know tied myself down to
watching this show about dragons and
whatever goes on well I loved being on
your podcast big cat it was a lot of fun
if I could change only one aspect of the
experience I would change the fact that
the photograph that we took on my show
set afterwards with the Lombardi Trophy
being placed directly in between my legs
I would change that because then because
all of your listeners picked up on that
and I didn't even see that when I posted
that photograph it's just a it you know
it's it's a learning experience in a way
for me being on your part
yeah the best way to win is to take a
bad picture I've been I've been
perfecting that for the last seven plus
years when you take a bad picture and
everyone can make fun of you for it
you've won the day you should see the
head shot we have for you right now on
the show we go I'm great terrible in
people people be tweeting it to me all
day long and it's beautiful nods very
it's very it's very gomez addams
actually it's what it looks actually
great it's very very good but like the
Raul Julia Gomez Addams that's someone
who in Game of Thrones all right thanks
for calling in thanks for having me on
your on your on your pot on your show
absolutely anytime your recurring guest
you have to come on when we ask it's
absolutely certain certainly since you
just cut me I've just been cut but if
you want to take me if you want to take
me off the cut list that's fine okay
thanks guys
take barstools Dan Katz the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience